John blit took JD on a canoe trip they
went down the Delaware River for JD
who's a terrible swimmer I saw the guy
almost drowned in a kitty pool for
[__] real blit kind of conned JD into
this because he told him it was going to
be a nice easy relaxing canoe trip I
thought it would be uhhuh I really did
but the river was high that day and JD
had much difficulty just putting on his
life jacket shut up blit what how the
hell do you loosen this goddamn thing
there's a third one here the 19-year-old
kid who worked there had to help him put
on like he's a little K I'm surprised
you got him in that boat cuz JD was not
happy right at right from the start to
the right I am right I I'm going to the
right oh these Rapids look pretty sick
oh [__] man God damn it oh [__] you all
right uh paddle I'm trying paddle on the
right right right I am I am I am I am
God damn it paddle paddle This is five
minutes into the canoe trip we dead Ser
the water was in the damn thing the
whole time the whole 4 hours my shoes
were soaked shoes and socks in the canoe
he said that it was going to be a nice
like smooth R and when JD gets really
manad he starts gruning like a caveman
he like regresses to early man he's like
the Hulk he's
like right side right side JD
okay left good stuff that's it no more
Rapids for now yeah for
now what is so [__] funny what did
you like about those Rapids got us all
[__] wet and now we got a [__]
spider on me and the [__] GoPro fell
God damn it paddle to the right okay God
watch this [__] boat I need a [__]
break God damn it blit I am miserable I
hate doing this oh thank God [__]
Christ how long was it 3 and a half
hours right yeah long enough once John
and JD finally made it to dry land they
headed to their
campsite oh [__] I was pointing at my
face pitching the tent setting up camp
actually went pretty smoothly but as
soon as they sat down to relax JD almost
choked on the water he was drinking you
go to I mean it's always a disaster
looming
J
nervous you all
right what
happened you all right I'm fine what
happened
damn what happened I'm
lying you all right [__] what happened
dude I I don't know you just drank too
fast I guess so what I guess so God damn
it look water's not your friend man I
mean no it's not you know what I love
about blit when somebody's choking on
food or water the worst thing to do is
to like to ask them to talk but B goes
right he goes what's going on
what's going
on oh he w't drink too fast you made it
to three and a half hours of the Rapids
only to be killed by a glass of water a
glass of
water they're like what happened did he
drown in the Delaware River and you
dragged him out no he was fine just
drank went down the wrong tube poor JD
everything goes wrong just wants to be
home the boys finally settled down and
the festivities got started with a
bottle of champagne of course and some
weed gummies and Ry whiskey he was
feeling all of
it yeah JD was so high he was mesmerized
by the Sparks coming out of the campire
uh fire is good drink is good whiskey is
[__]
great okay any final words it might
about 10 it's
10 incoherent J more
pass out we put one more log in I'm not
going to pass out during this [__]
log but
whatever you can't even understand them
normally I know what he just said look
there he is unconscious but good he was
so drunk that he passed out on the 10th
floor he's doesn't even have a like he
doesn't even have a sleeping bag no
nothing he's just there he sweat through
that sleeping bag oh jeez listen I'm a
sweater I I you know I don't know anyway
there you go all right there it is the
exclusive JD camping with John
blit